I've been talking about two important
things that Joe Biden should do right now,
in addition to figuring out, of course, his
cabinet and his advisers. And those two things are
immediately establish a parallel coronavirus task
force, even while Donald Trump is still president.
And number two, start putting together a list of
Donald Trump's fiascos that Joe Biden can undo
by executive order. A lot you can't do
by executive order, but a lot you can.
And Joe Biden is doing both of these things.
I'm going to talk about the coronavirus task
force separately, but we've already learned
that Joe Biden is planning an immediate
flurry of executive orders to, on day one, reverse
some of the most harebrained Trump policies
so far. The list we have of what Biden
will do immediately after taking office
includes no one rejoining the Paris climate
accords must do. It's not nearly enough,
but it's the first step in starting to reintegrate
the United States into the international community
that is taking climate change seriously. Rejoined
the Paris Climate Accords, reverse Donald Trump's
withdrawal from the World Health Organization,
which he did announce during a pandemic.
It is not fully happened. So Joe Biden, hopefully,
thanks to Trump's incompetence, he's not fully
carried out some of the harebrained decisions he
made. Joe Biden will repeal that Muslim majority
country travel ban. Of course, what we need
is actual targeted screening of individuals.
And primarily, if you want to make it a country
focus, you would focus on the countries that have
sent terrorists Trump, not even including
those countries on his list. So Joe Biden
will reverse that. Joe Biden will reinstate the
Dreamers program, very, very important relating
to immigration. Joe Biden will reinstate dozens of
environmental and business regulations that Donald
Trump undid, which allowed pollution and so much
else. And Joe Biden also expected to immediately
repeal that ridiculous military transgender
ban. Now, you might remember that under
Barack Obama, executive orders were tyranny. Under
Trump, executive orders were necessary and heroic,
according to the American right. You can be sure
that they are going to do the exact same thing
this time, saying Biden is tyranny with executive
orders because there is so much damage that Joe
Biden has to undo. My advice is we don't even
engage in that conversation. We keep it simple.
Trump was an unmitigated disaster. It is an
emergency that Joe Biden start his presidency,
undoing as much of what Trump destroyed as he can.
Trump's entire end game was undoing the Obama
legacy. Is there something poetic about losing to
Barack Obama's vice president who then will start
undoing the disasters of Donald Trump? The problem
is that the Republican right wing, wacky Supreme
Court is at the ready right now. So it will be
different for Joe Biden than it was for Donald
Trump. Fortunately, the best legal analysis I've
read so far is that most of what Joe Biden plans
to do via executive order is not challengeable
in any way that that it would pull in the Supreme
Court. The problem will be that even with Biden
rejoining things like the Waco and Paris climate,
if you're another country, you realize that while
these are the right decisions today, you can say
Biden's doing the right thing. You now know
that just as quickly if we get another Trump in,
they could just bail. Undoing years of work,
Trump destroyed decades of trust and confidence,
and that will take much longer than
some day. One executive orders to undo.
But we will be following all of it.
And I encourage you to follow us
on Instagram at David Pakman
show. And while you're there,
follow me on Instagram at David Pakman, The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com